c'est un endroit tenu secret une grotte
à plus de 30 mètres sous terre depuis
2014 environ 70 bénévoles se relaient
tous les week-ends entre mars et octobre
pour déblayer les sédiments qui dureront
des centaines de milliers d'années se
sont déposés ici charriées par une
rivière
cette rivière a amené des sédiments du
sable des graviers des galets c'est ce
que l'on voit sur les côtés et a tous
rempli en fait total rock mais la grotte
elle fait 12 mètres de large parle plus
de 8 mètres de hauteur 100 tonnes de
sédiments déjà enlevé pas moins de 8000
sont acheminés vers l'extérieur par un
chariot sur rail et soudain au fond de
la grotte devant notre caméra
une découverte extraordinaire vous avez
trouvé coincé mais tel un grosse quelque
chose qui est très rare c'est un losc à
plus de 600 millions notre belle taille
on a la continuité ici donc on va
essayer de le dégager
cette grotte de calcaire et comme un
livre ouvert sur l'histoire de la terre
chaque numéro correspond à un
prélèvement envoyé pour être daté dans
des universités en france et dans le
monde et à 780 mille ans le magnétisme
de la terre s'est inversée comme on a
une date au dessus à 600 mille ans on
peut espérer dans toute cette couche de
sédiments retrouver l'inversion du
magnétisme terrestre mais la trouvaille
la plus marquante dans cette grotte ces
sept dents de mammouth méridionale un
mastodonte de 10 tonnes
apparu il ya deux à trois millions
d'années disparu il ya six ans milan
avec tous ses ex estrie que l'on vaut
c'est ce qui a permis de déterminer
l'espèce en fait de mammouth
et puis enfin il ya cette stalagmites
que le muséum d'histoire naturelle a pu
dater votre 500 et 600 mille ans en fait
on est capable aujourd'hui d'aller
chercher sur chaque la mine les isotopes
du carbone et d'oxygène et d'avoir le
climat la température à chaque dépôt
cette étude coûte 30 mille euros les
spéléologues espère le sénat